je vous propose maintenant un détour par
perpignan avec cette initiative
originale et généreuse des organisateurs
du festival visa pour l'image
la reconstitution d'une tente où des
parents du rwanda tente de retrouver
leurs enfants dispersés
cela grâce aux photos prises par
l'unicef ou encore les responsables de
la croix-rouge reportage thiriez fils
jasselin cela commence par une galerie
de portrait sans concession artistique
et pour cause
douze mille petites photos sans nom
juste un numéro des enfants rwandais à
la recherche de leurs parents
et ça marche 3500 enfants ont déjà
retrouvé une famille
grâce à cette tente de l'espoir utilisé
au rwanda par l'unisep des visages qui
ont disent probablement plus long que
n'importe quel reportage réaction d'une
touriste américaine
c'est une des choses les plus fortes que
j'ai jamais vu c'est vraiment terrible
la façon dont ils regardent
quelques mètres plus loin une autre
guerre la tchétchénie
trente et une exposition dans une
ancienne caserne ou dans une vieille
prison ici tous les genres se côtoient
véronique vial française qui vit aux
états unis a eu l'idée d'aller mettre
son gros objectif avant 10 heures du
matin sous le nez d'hommes célèbres pas
réveiller du tout robert altman dans
l'intimité
karl lagerfeld pour la postérité
arthur miller agacé et barbet schroeder
c'est drôle je pense qu'il avait changé
d'avis dans la nuit et j'ai eu un
pressentiment de j'arrivais une heure en
avance et en fait il est en train de
s'habiller pour partir
laurent rebours photographe d'actualité
le président et l'ouvrier regard
malicieux des deux côtés c'était un
instant une étincelle mais il fallait
être là pour bien comprendre comment ils
travaillent
nous l'avons suivi dans le quartier
gitan
ces gens sont là j'ai peur qu'ils posent
j'accueille savent que faire donc je
vais attendre ce pâté chaud soudain le
cas là le petit oiseau est sorti vous
l'avez compris pour avoir une chance que
sa photo finissent dans un canard il
faut être précis mais jamais pressé
voilà